ragazzi non sto a fare ringraziamenti
per i 5 milioni di iscritti perché lo
speciale dove c'è tutto quanto lo stiamo
preparando da circa un mese uscirà
questo sabato quindi per i 5 milioni
iscritti
lo speciale sabato 22 quindi tra due
giorni sarà incredibile
ve lo assicuro adesso devo finire di
fare delle robe appunto per lo speciale
intanto vi lascio al video di oggi non
mancate sabato
c'è stato un tempo in cui le favole
facevano parte della nostra vita in cui
i miei video non iniziavano parlando al
microfono tenete gli occhi
potete mi piace il video potete fatica
chiusa vabbè si può mettere mi piace a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono falli già oggi siamo su
gretel e hansel gretel e hansel è un
gioco che avevo fatto e ogni fa e mi
ricordo che era bellissimo in questo
momento di pausa visto che vacanze
natale bebè facciamo un una ripresa tipo
destino di uno dei capolavori diciamo
confortato sul canale perché questa
fosse a livello di feedback di metascore
è uno di quelli che è piaciuto di più di
video che ho portato e non mi ricordano
è stata dura pochissimo ma ne vale la
pena
benvenuti in rete è un sogno ma che
bello che carino la scritta blake e gli
alberi che crescono vabbè dai era una
figata
parte 1 pietre che ha il plurale di
pietro o quattro fatto bene però sono
giochi in flash
c'è una tipa che fu ma c'è uno con la
testa d'uovo e pazzia è sta roba del
mezzo pitturato sembra fighissimo alzati
l'altro dormiamo in una cosa bruttissima
ha preso a simone con wise di a posso
sbirciare dall'olio dal cugino ok ma
sono i nostri genitori il padre non ha i
capelli ma i baffi ricerca e temporanea
milano via milano siamo in tibet ha
paura che da tempesta ammazzi la
famiglia con la dove interpreta però
mangiamo le patate il che ci rende
felici basta mangiare patate potremmo
andare nella foresta e nella foresta
calcio abbandonare i nostri bambini
calciando lì e poi le patate le avremo
solo noi due
noda anche brutta roba a stanno
litigando su sta cosa
che mamma brutta che ci abbiamo perché
la nostra mamma ci vuole abbandonare
cosa abbia fatto come fratello fratello
nell'occhio proprio non mi caga no no
oggi occhio svegliati però devi
svegliare city colpisco infatti è felice
lui a mangia ha fatto colazione 5 stelle
quest'hotel le mosche ora mi aveva detto
che c'è il temporale che ci vuole
abbandonare perché le patate non bastano
per tutti allora c'è programma coppa
nella foresta cd calciano e moriamo per
capito
andiamo vieni che dobbiamo scappare
prima che ci abbandonino abbandoniamoci
da soli vice posta lo bravo il fratello
è stupido pro chissenefrega gli vogliamo
bene lo stesso non mi ricordo
assolutamente come può finire un gioco
così cavolo è bellissimo è riuscito no
sto andare tipo di qua asini che figata
la manovella
no no ma è stata la scelta più brutta
che riportasse gioco sul mio cane che
schifo ma dai che schifo rega schiatta
mori non finirà bene
fammi prova a vedere le situazioni il
signor ragno posso prendere il coso no
bene allora avete tutti queste cose che
non ho capito cosa siano ma mi servono
quindi per cortesia signor coniglio
venga un attimo venga con me va bè non
importa fa niente serve lo scoiattolo da
offrire in tributo a quella roba lì per
favore mi trovate uno scoiattolo è
scappato via coniglio dammi la mano
maledizione damian malato allo
scoiattolo cioccolando il coniglio va
bene dagli bacini a pignone mente che
dai bacini e coniglio perché non lo
portiamo dal ragno o si infila a c'è una
moneta di sotto prendi a premia col
secchio live view
quindi trovo anche oggetti dietro le
cose che ce n'è una tipo ma c'è un fungo
qua con il fungo posso tirare attenzione
a farti p ha trovato la al cinema la
cosa qua perfetto preso un botto c'è
ancora una ghianda da trovare due su tre
forse con le ghiande posso attirare lo
scoiattolo forze cioè sarà una tipo qua
vieni qua stavo quasi per l'ho preso
porca vacca che sfidavano le ghiande
mettere lì guardalo lì in questo punto
ragazzi ne vedo 31 cielo allo scoiattolo
1 e lì è uno è lì sotto
quindi ottimo
l'eco dello scoiattolo non posso mettere
la ghianda per attirarlo ma scusami ma
ecco mi sembrava strano
vai vai tratte dai dai mi allontano mi
allontana che sono lontano sono
tantissimo e muoviti ecco ciao grazie
mille ascoltami servire sti anche per un
altro compito dovrei prendere la
monetina da e il ragno c'è la rai vieni
a darmi una mano per favore a chi libero
dai guarda quanto sono bravo a sì perché
il fungo dove sono morte ha urtato
addosso
chiaramente le api hanno paura del
berutti può immergersi pesce a noi
questo perché ma perché adesso posso
usarlo come esca tutto verde
mamma mia ciao premio crediop rende
veloce prima che ti mangi la famiglia
anzi si mangia la famiglia è meglio
visto che non è proprio il massimo
adesso ci sta raccontando le fatto ci
vuole portare fuori quindi ma cos'è papa
non perché non sei tu che porti i
pantaloni in casa spiega mi si ho capito
lo so dobbiamo fare dobbiamo raccogliere
le cose alcuno spazio posso saltare
molto bene e ha raggiunto la foresta
hai visto se non fosse che questa cosa
non assenza ecco ci hanno abbandonati
hai visto hansel te l'ho detto io che
alla fine non avrebbe avuto senso
maledetta famiglia mio padre che non ha
nei capelli nella dignità mannaia
questo era il primo capitolo di rete
lance andiamo col secondo gra dell'anas
gill nets che abbiamo bisogno di capire
innanzitutto cosa sono sti cosi un
ciuffo d'erba
c'è un ciuffo ai mio fratello
cosa ci fai lì sotto e mio padre a lui
non ne esce il ciuffo perché non ce li
hai capelli era vero questo gioco è
veramente strano e bellissimo vero
perché se la transizione dalla rete lan
sull 1 a 2
molto molto simpatico questa mia madre
non mi tira una clavata era un sogno era
un sogno anselmi svegliati ci ha portati
nella foresta ma non hai visto non vede
niente non sa niente
cos'è sta roba hai una lettera di papa
che c'è il cuore con papi mi ha lasciato
delle cose una bistecca che cosa grazie
papà ti voglio bene anch'io non ci
possiamo fare niente se mamma lavora in
tangenziale
tieni svegliati come i cani uguale
grazie genti guara severamente di una
gentilezza incredibile per aver
condiviso doveva andare a casa seguimi
che si è rotta la fionda ma no i sei
scassata la fionda ma come non ci credo
sono cascato di sotto da posso bere però
devo nel mentre spunta sulla torta sport
bravo bravo non ci avevo pensato è
potuto dar fuoco all'albero pia dai
riparativa
no è morto il mio amico che sfiga vabbè
dai grazie mille
location per me almeno sette perché
caratteristica voto 222 facendo tutto
schifo ansell cosa fai qui scusami per i
ragazzi questa è la rete le enzo devono
fare anche il 3 in realtà purtroppo non
si può continuare da quel punto lì
perché il gioco si bug non si sa perché
ma dopo quel punto non si può più
giocare peccato perché anche resterà
molto figo spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come al solito se il video è
piaciuto c'è un documento è un mi piace
anche a vari social che condividono la
descrizione solo se avessi siete noi ci
vediamo al prossimo vito da ragazzi
[Musica]
no